- You spent time in Berlin
for your new project?
- Yeah.
- And you had a roommate, right?
- Yes, I did.
It was a studio apartment
and it was at this very, very,
very old building in Berlin.
A lot of probably terrible
things happened there.
And I was moving in and
I was putting my stuff
in this dresser.
And all of a sudden I smelled perfume.
And I was like, what is going on?
Is this like such a fancy place
that they push perfume through the vents?
And then I very quickly
realized that I had a roommate
and I feel like she had
been there since like
I wanna say the forties.
- You mean like a ghost?
- Yeah, I named her Olga.
- And you stayed in it?
- Yes.
- What is happening?
- We created a relationship.
Like she was very sweet.
Her name was not Olga.
I did ask her that
but I couldn't figure out her actual name.
So I asked if it was
okay to call her Olga.
And she was like, "Yeah, whatever."
- What?
Like, I'm freaking
I'm so terrified of stuff like that.
Not terrified.
I just don't even wanna know it exists
if it exists, like, and
you're saying it exists
which terrifies me.
There's enough going on in this realm.
- Oh yes.
- I don't wanna have to
worry about another one.
That's insane.
And it didn't scare you at all.
Have you been like that,
like since you were a kid?
- Oh yes.
My mom taught me how to read tarot cards
when I was a kid.
She reads palms.
- I'm obsessed right now with tarot cards.
I think they're so fun.
- It's great.
It's amazing.
- Sometimes really dead on, yeah.
- Yeah.
I mean, if you put like
the right energy into it
and ask the right questions,
you can really be able to,
it's not a future teller by any mean,
but you can really be able
to understand the situation,
where other people come are coming from.
But yeah, no, when I was a kid
I saw dead people all the time.
- What in the world?
- Yeah.
I can't see them anymore.
- Okay.
See, that's my problem.
See, I'm a very open person
and that's what scares me
'cause I literally let
people like, let go whatever.
I'm like, I walk in
somewhere, somebody says
I'm like, I'm really cool if you're here.
Like, but like, just don't show yourself.
(Sarah laughs)
Like we can both be here.
We don't have to know.
- I don't wanna know what you look like.
- Yeah, I'm like, I don't wanna see you.
'Cause I'm such an open
person, I feel like that they
it would happen to me
and then I would die.
- Oh no.
- Yeah, I would die.
- You just have to be
able to protect yourself
and it's good.
- I am not that person.
I just like to avoid it.